[Music]
you guys look incredible there
I thought that happens already put on
that baby
we're living in crazy times you never
know what's going to happen stop I love
that you have this flash what is in here
I would I want to know a beverage no
arty beverage
what's the naughty beverage anything
good Rosie
I love Rosie Rosie I am of legal age I
know I look younger but I love your
grill tell me about the process of
getting ready tonight and how many
office did you choose well no we knew we
wanted to go with camouflage from the
very start we started with the flak
jacket and then we worked our way down
and inside so you know we're ready we're
ready amazing sort of fashionable yeah
combat barbering Heather how are the
twins doing they're great
yes stay up they also approve of my
outfit I mean when you're dressing be
incredible incomparable Madonna is the
pressure on like how is your process
together you know what honestly I have
the most fun dressing her more than
anyone else I'll tell you why it's such
a celebration she is the most creative
person I've ever worked with she brings
so much to it it's not the same thing as
like oh here's the sketch and his idea
it's a collaboration it's a friendship
is something that's more passionate so
it's and it's fun it doesn't hurt that
she's so beautiful and everything books
they were right up on the wall
oh yeah okay thanks these guys together
this is gonna be a fun night yeah
you're fun nice as long as I drink the
rest of my candies
[Music]
you